[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
there's a free game available right now
but it's only for a limited time
and it's available to all platforms ps4
ps5 epic games xbox
and even stadia who the heck has a
stadia right now you can grab
far cry 5 the entire game sounds pretty
good right
well this is a limited time offer
between 7am on august 5th which is
hopefully today when you're watching
this
through to the 9th so 96 hours of time
to play this one
so you could actually platinum this by
the way there's a shortcut ending if you
want to flex on your friends and finish
this in five minutes flat
essentially though this is a free
weekend to get people hyped for far cry
6
which arrives later in the year in the
past there has been a bit of a glitch
and some free ubisoft weekends haven't
actually ended so there's a slight
chance you can play this outside of the
five-day window
and on the other hand the full game is
massively discounted too
i mean ridiculously cheap if you like it
you may struggle to find this in the
store so use the search function and the
free version is actually classed as a
demo
at least here on the ps5 a little
awkward but the free version
is there if you know where to look while
you download this i'll tell you about it
far cry 5 is an open world action
adventure game in which you travel to
the usa
and the state of hub county to take down
a fanatical doomsday cult known as
eden's gate
along the way you'll be hunting fishing
crafting and generally just blowing
things up with a dog called boomer
insert your own boomer joke here the
game is broken into areas with their own
sub boss to take down before you get
your chance to face off with the typical
far cry bad guy who's strangely
compelling this is joseph seed
otherwise known as the father i really
recommend the multiplayer mode as
playing co-op with a buddy is a great
time but you will need ps plus or xbox
live if you play multiplayer on console
sad but true the game is three years old
so keep that in mind
and you should have a good time and a
good weekend i plan to cover far cry 6
in a great deal of detail over the next
few months
so stick around and think about pressing
subscribe go on give it a tickle
i'm adam you're awesome i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you